we're waiting we're waiting and once
you're back into your PI or desktop is
back it was good now what we'd like to
do let's go ahead and check and make
sure that we did everything right
saved and everything's hunky-dory so
what we're gonna want to type in here is
the same thing we kind of before that
was given us a 0 we sent these cgn C and
E get on our spore config arm ours or
correctly C and now as you can see it is
definitely reading at 800 so we did save
that correctly and you might notice a
slight increase of your performance now
there's also other things that you can
do like overclocking your RAM so how
would we do that if we wanted to
overclock the RAM well say anything
we're gonna pop into that in from the
mouse sudo nano / boot / take that text
and I should bring up our file then
again we'll just put it kind of with our
other overclock setting here down and so
now what you can do is SDRAM underscore
frequency and you can set this let's say
I think the default is at 200 so we can
set this to 300 so now we so I'm sorry I
hit ctrl s to used to operating on like
Windows
EXIF ignored mumble mumble I don't even
know what I did anyway
exit we're gonna save and save it to the
same file and let's run this again
and we want to get the SDRAM frequency
so as you can see it's reading zero
because we haven't synced so let's try
see so zero will do but it's really
hoping to avoid another shutdown but
let's just one more time
No okay so we're gonna have to go
through the entire process again so I'm
gonna go ahead and do it I'm just going
to type it out really quick so and
actually I think all we really have to
do is shut down and restart to be honest
that ought to do it
but anyway just just in case you you
need to go through the sync process
we'll just do it really quick so see
those saying sudo SH - Rob underscore
cache should be good
next thing I'm going to do COC PE and
big Xbox save and - just go up to the
neck like the line you previously type
it up the up arrow by the way I don't
think I mentioned that a second ago now
see those sing sing X okay open it one
more time back up over on a pseudo Sing
se
and then we're gonna shut it down oops
pseudo shutdown - hmm goodbye
alright guys so once you've actually
restarted open up the LX terminal one
last time and what we want to do is
check the RAM and then while we're at it
we'll just check the CPU one last time
well you should probably notice that
your terminal ran a little bit quicker
upload or came up a little bit quicker
for you but anyway vc g en CMD get our
score config and then you want your
SDRAM underscore pregnancy and as you
can see now it is reading 300 same thing
we can do with our arm an arm is just a
reference to your processor what you're
running an ARM processor anyway so now
that's 800 we are now successfully
overclocked and we did it all by
ourselves now if if you want to know how
to get into your Raspberry Pi
configuration anyways because it is
actually pretty beneficial to at least
know what's possible I will now show you
that real quick if you don't have a new
version of Raspberry Pi and you haven't
got the latest version of the Raspberry
Pi firmware then what you'll want to do
is the following command I'm not going
to enter in it myself but if you don't
have it then this would be the command
you would do sudo app and you want to
get update and then and and sudo apt -
yeah and then you want to install
Raspberry Pi everything and RasPi - con
fig now this kind of let me see here
real quick if I can there we go nice one
line for you if you don't have the
latest version of your firmware so
anyway back to Big Boi litters the next
thing that we want to do is pull up that
configuration utility and the way that
we're going to do that sudo brass PI -
and that pulls up that car it's it's not
a BIOS but it just kind of reminds me of
a BIOS so this is kind of the thing that
you saw the first time you installed
your operating system so here you can
edit your user password you can enable
boot to desktop which I don't recommend
you could do the camera but then anyway
we get down to overclock and you come
into overclock and it just warns you
that you could reduce the lifetime of
your raspberry pi now the only thing I
will just say on top of this is what
kills a processor over time is heat and
heat only pretty much I guess water
could do it too but this is badass when
do you like 900 and 250 anyway so heat
is what does it so right now if you've
got no case right you're just kind of
free airing it the Raspberry Pi it
should stay you know relatively cool but
the best way to keep your Raspberry Pi
cool is to have it by a fan or something
that is going to continue moving away
the hot Erik so you can put your finger
don't touch it but you can put your
finger over your processor and you can
feel that it's giving off heat so the
best thing for you to do is to move that
heat immediately once it comes off of
the processor so anyway that's that
that's pretty much everything you need
to know when it comes to overclocking
and you know how to do it yourself or to
just use the settings that they give you
I want this ok give me this overclock
thank you I'm done so anyway just keep
that in mind when you do overclock that
it's highly likely that your well you're
probably its own it's certain that your
processor will run hotter so just keep
that in mind as you as you you know kind
of play around with your overclocking so
anyways that's going to conclude the
overclocking tutorial as always thanks
for watching hopefully you guys learned
something about your new toy
thank you for your support your
subscriptions and until next time